- [Voiceover] The picture has an
area of 80 square centimeters.
What is the width of the picture?
So here's our picture, this super
fun giraffe listening to music
and our picture's shape is a rectangle
and we're asked to find the
width of that rectangle.
Well, maybe we don't
know a special formula
or a special equation to find width,
but we do know one to
find area of a rectangle,
so let's use that formula
and see how it can help us.
We know that area of a
rectangle can be found
by multiplying the
length of the rectangle,
over here, the length, times the width.
So if we multiply the two side lengths
of a rectangle, we get its area.
And on this picture, in this rectangle,
we are told that our area
is 80 square centimeters,
so we already know the area,
and we can use that to help us.
We also know the length.
We're told that this
distance from here to here,
this length is 10 centimeters,
so the length is 10.
Times the width, we don't know the width.
That's what we're looking for.
So what we do know though,
is that we need our width
to be a number that when
it's multiplied times 10,
we get 80 for an answer.
So what number times
10 equals 80 is eight.
Eight time 10 equals 80.
So that means the width of our picture
is eight centimeters.
Let's try one more.
A rectangle has an area
of 24 square meters.
The width of the rectangle is four meters.
What is the length of the rectangle?
So this time we don't even
have a picture to look at,
but we have enough information
up here to solve this.
Again, we can use our
formula that tells us
area of a rectangle is the
length times the width.
Now we could draw this rectangle.
It might be helpful to visualize it,
but I'm gonna show you here,
we can actually solve it
without ever even seeing the rectangle,
because we know the area
is 24 square meters,
so the space the rectangle
covers is 24 square meters,
and the length, we don't know the length.
We're asked what is the length.
But we do know that the
width is four meters.
So our length has to be some number
that when it's multiplied times four,
we get 24 for the answer.
And that number must be six,
because six times four equals 24.
So the length of our rectangle is six,
and in this case we're
talking about meters, meters.